you know nan exorcism really isn't as
extraordinary as one might think in fact
every living being has this innate
ability
to become one just in a very particular
way and in this case you can exercise
and banish your boredom by subscribing
to the new world review which will
result in regular hunt onto content
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today it's hunter hunter time
once more as we are looking into a very
niche brand of menus being that
of ned exorcism and i've spoken about
these figures briefly in a couple of
videos but not too much because they are
incredibly rare individuals whose
abilities aren't
uh well they're not particularly
versatile however with that said there
is still quite the call for near nexus
due to another sub-branch of the art
form which is known as nen curses and
i've done a whole
video on them link in the description
below if you're keen to learn more but a
basic example of a nen curse would be
krapik's judgment chain
which was used on three members of the
phantom troop and resulted in the deaths
of two
meanwhile other curses include gentry's
countdown and even nakosakawara falls
under the category of nen curse despite
the fact that it is also a nen beast
interestingly but despite the fact that
the existence of nen
is one of the best kept secrets in the
world the fact that curses exist
has given rise to a response to them
which has taken its form in the realm of
exorcism and to explore this some more
let's head over to our first and most
profound example of a nan
exorcist being ambengano now we know
this fine fellow from the other divisive
greed island arc which actually features
an entire subplot based on nern exorcism
and that is an aspect of greed island i
feel often gets quite forgotten
in favor of remembering some glorious
dodgeball but the entire reason why both
hisoka and the phantom troupe were
involved here at all was the search for
an nx cyst
in order to remove karapica's judgement
chain from crowler and i think that very
much goes on to display how
rare these practitioners are because it
would seem that if you want an
organization like say the hunter
association
it turns out that it is no simple task
to source a nan exorcist so much so the
phantom troop had to resort to delving
into a game to do so however as for
abengana himself he would be the first
to display the basic way in which nan
exorcism technically works which does
vary depending on your nan affinity in
our benghani's case he is a conjurer so
his brand of exorcism will make use of
conjuration
which is not necessarily true in every
other case but basically in order to
remove a curse ambengano has the
condition of setting up something of a
ritual whereby he needs to start a
campfire
as well as construct an effigy and
engage in prayer to the forest spirits
and with that in mind i assume that
abengana also needs to be in a forest
to perform a nexus however i would say
that we should not be confused by the
the theatricality of this setup it's
more than likely that these are
limitations that arben ghana has
subconsciously imposed on himself
in order to engage with his abilities
which may even go on to make his
exorcisms more powerful or efficient
than that of others
mostly because i highly highly doubt
that given everything we know of the
hunt hunt world that there is a more
spiritual element to it and as such this
whole ritual business is more than
likely a result of abengane's background
however religious
or traditionalists that may be in any
case as we would soon learn an exorcism
is not a simple removal or dispelling of
indian curse
sadly nen doesn't exactly work like that
and the power inflicted upon a victim by
an n curse more accurately needs to be
traded in for something else
which unfortunately for the existing
question will generally be inflicting
them
rather than the initial curse victim so
remember when i said that abengano was a
conjurer well the result of him removing
an incurs is that he goes on to conjure
and then beast the size of which is in
direct correlation to the power of the
curse removed and rather
awkwardly that beast then attaches
itself to abungani until the original
conditions of said curse
are met now conditions on a curse look
most name curses come with a crafted
limitation
by the creator to make them more
powerful and the beast you are seeing on
our benghani was created by removing
genthru's countdown ability which
charbon gun it did claim was quite
powerful
i guess implying that the majority of
nanexisms probably would not result in a
beast quite this big but genthru's
countdown did have a condition for
removal which is that the target has to
touch again through himself and say i
caught the bomber at which point the
countdown hatsu will vanish entirely
so that's the very tricky tricky balance
of not just being in a nexus but
engaging in a nexism because in some way
or another the exorcist will be
sacrificing their own well-being for the
sake of an afflicted victim and to put
it another way they will basically be
inflicting themselves with the same
curse but just in a different form
now i mention conditions for curses
because this becomes very fascinating
to think about in regards to abengane's
next exorcism which would be removing
karopika's judgment chain from kroller
now sadly this would be an exorcism that
we did not get to see with our own eyes
however we do know for a fact that it
happened because sabangana left greed
island with hisoka
claiming that he was about to make an
absolute fortune on a nexism and then
the next time we see crollo well he is
back in action and able to use then
again as well as contact the other troop
members now i don't think that there is
any dispute the judgement chain is just
empirically more powerful than countdown
which means that the nen beast that
would have needed to be conjured by
abangana as a result
would have been a much more massive than
this comparatively teeny tiny thing that
we saw on greed island but the thing i
do worry about most though is that yes
the judgment chain has conditions
in which kravika gets to inflict rules
on his targets however this curse does
not have a condition
under which it can be dispelled at least
not one that we know of and this of
course
is intentionally constructed by karapika
because he planned on using it to take
revenge on the troop and so he did not
want to give them any way out however
that puts abengana in a rather rough
position because after successfully
performing this exorcism it could very
well have left him with no way to dispel
the curse that he had taken upon himself
and i mean yes he at the very least
assumedly does not have crawler's
conditions imposed on him but i don't
see how it would have been possible for
him to rid himself
of the conjugand beast and also this
assumes that abengane survived the
exorcism process to begin with another
rather unfortunate aspect about abengan
abengane's nernexism
is that he does not become aware of
exactly how powerful the nenenkus is
until he engages in the process by which
point it is far
far too late to do anything about it so
he has to use very clear judgment before
beginning in axism
which he does seem to have as he did
correctly gauge the strength of gentru's
curse but then again that curse was
inflicted upon upping ghana directly
whereas the judgment chain was on
another person which would have
potentially made it much harder for
abangani to gain an accurate reflection
of power so i guess what i'm suggesting
is that it's entirely possible that arba
ghana currently lives in a state of
living hell with a gigantic beast upon
him that he is unable to remove
or that maybe armangana had to conjure
an nb so large that it crushed and
killed him but in any case i don't think
things worked out particularly well for
this
individual nan exorcist so let's put
amangana to the side and look at another
exorcist another often forgotten example
from the chimera antarctic being hina
who was a squad captain under lao's
command who also just so happened to be
an
cyst now in hina's case she was a
specialist so it's very hard to dissect
exactly how she technically uses her
abilities but they have a very distinct
correlation to abagana's powers which is
that after removing a curse ina takes
that power onto herself which in this
case inflates her stomach with the
amount of inflation being related to the
potency of the curse
now as for what cursed in the series
hina removed well she was actually
responsible for freeing chitu from
knuckles hakuwara which is another very
powerful curse and the more i think
about hakuwa the crazier it becomes
so it had the effect of making hina look
like she was well
pretty desperately pregnant very
interestingly though this was an awkward
situation for hina because the condition
for removing hakuwa was to pay back the
aura loaned by knuckle which she most
certainly never did and in fact i don't
think the two of them were
ever anywhere near each other but hina
would recover anyway very coincidentally
right after chi 2 was sorted by silva
zoldick which provides us with another
fascinating interaction because despite
taking the curse upon herself
it would seem that the curse was still
tied to its original target
so once chitu was removed from this
world the curse was taken along with it
now i definitely can't say if this would
be the case for all nenexis for example
if crowler were to die
then would arbengana if indeed he was
still alive immediately have his
conjured end beast removed as a result
it's mostly difficult to say because
once again hina was a specialist so she
could have had a very unique condition
in play that keeps the connection to her
target however there is admittedly a
possibility that this could be a
universal standard of existence now
sadly we have very few other examples of
nenexist and much less specific
abilities but in the manga we do have a
confirmed exorcist in umama who is the
bodyguard of second prince camilla in
the succession war although we
ultimately know nothing about her at
this stage other than the fact that she
can
indeed engage in this art form which
actually makes camilla's faction far
more dangerous than anybody gives her
credit for
because it is a super super handy thing
to have a nexus by your side
elsewhere in the succession war you
could potentially make the argument that
rehan's predator ability is a form of no
nexism although it is quite a flimsy
case i mean under the right conditions
it does counter and remove non-abilities
which was seen in the case of 8th prince
salazar beast and it did have
repercussions on rihann himself which
was simply that he was unable
to use nen for 48 hours after predator
had acted but at the same time that
could just be a basic known limitation
so look it might be a very different
brand of excision or an entirely new
subclass of nine all on its own and some
people may also remember the axis that
was brought in to help gone after the
events of the chimera antar
and this would be the individual who
claimed that there was no exorcist in
existence that could remove the curse
that gon had placed on himself which
makes a lot of sense because this is by
far the most powerful use of nen that we
have ever seen in the series and as such
it came with an equal amount of
consequences this does bring up an
important factor which is that nexus
also run into a problem with post-mortem
nancosas in general because they are by
nature's superpowered effects of aura
that far surpass the general
capabilities of living end wielders with
that said post-mortem then is not
impossible to deal with
unlike gone's situation but it has been
quite literally stated that there are
less than 10 exodus in this world who
have the ability to remove a curse
invoked with post-mortem nine and the
hunter who was engaged to trick gone may
very well be one of those
because she was a seemingly highly
trusted member of the association but
this does go on to imply that there are
some very
like extraordinarily powerful people out
there that we very much have yet to meet
and what's also interesting to think
about
is if you need to access a particular
affinity of nen to develop an x-ismhatsu
so the two examples that we've seen
conjuration and specialization while
they make all the sense in the world
because they can take that curse aura
and convert it into something else
however not all nem branches can
necessarily serve that function for
example enhancement and manipulation and
two disciplines that i would say are
unlikely to be able to access sexism but
not
impossible like perhaps maybe a curse
could be removed and inflicted upon your
body in the case of an enhancer they do
very much see emitters and transmuters
being able to perform xs-0 because they
can very deliberately mould their aurora
like a transmuter could create a cursed
substance that follows them perhaps even
a raw name beast to compensate but in
the end the whole exorcist curse dynamic
is one of those fantastically underrated
features of hunter hunter and it does
add a great layer of depth to the
empower system
as well as the world itself actually and
the rarity of such figures and events
only serves to make them far more
captivating when they do
indeed happen in the series and that
pretty much does it for this discussion
of net exorcisms but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're game for
some more hunt onto content then please
do go and check out some of my other
videos or even subscribe to the channel
for regular hunt hunter glory delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time